hey everyone this is Lucy I'm a
Solutions architect working at AWS and
in this video I'm going to be explaining
to you why you should not become a
Solutions architect all right let me
take a step back and explain why when
you first come across the world of cloud
computing you probably started to see
the phrase Solutions Architects thrown
around everywhere people talk about how
the solutions Arctic job pays a lot of
money and you get to work with cool
technology every day there's even two
AWS certifications named after the
solutions architect title but this role
isn't for everyone not everyone should
become an AWS Solutions architect and no
I'm not saying that you don't have what
it takes to become an AWS Solutions
architect I truly believe that anyone
can become whatever they want as long as
they set their mind to achieving it what
I'm saying is it's important for you to
find a career that aligns with your
personality your interests and what you
find fulfilling what a lot of people
don't understand about the solutions
architect role is that just like every
other role it comes with a lot of things
you may enjoy but also a lot of things
that make you want to pull your hair out
and of course how much you end up liking
the role all depends on who you are as a
person I'm going to be sharing five
reasons you should not become a
Solutions architect and at the end of
this video I'd encourage all of you to
comment below whether you still like to
become a Solutions architect or maybe
consider a different career path this
video is honestly not me trying to
convince you not to become a Solutions
architect I just want to provide you
with the transparency of what it's
actually like working in this kind of
role if 99 of you in the comments say
you still want to become a Solutions
architect that's really great but if I
can help the other one percent realize
that this role isn't actually what they
expected it to be then I hope some
people save some time and money in their
career with all that being said let's
jump straight into it reason number one
you should not become an AWS Solutions
architect if you don't enjoy interacting
with customers this is a big one as a
Solutions architect I spend almost every
day talking to customers whether that's
meeting them over a video call or
sending emails back and forth it's quite
rare for me to have many days in a row
where I just sit in front of my laptop
all day and do my work without talking
to anyone the main responsibility of an
AWS Solutions architect is to be a
trusted technical advisor for companies
looking to build things in the cloud so
if you're someone who doesn't like the
idea of spending the next three to five
years of your career working directly
with customers then this role is not for
you reason number two you should not
become an AWS Solutions architect if
you're not willing to continuously learn
and build new skills at AWS all
solutions Architects have one thing in
common we all have to sharpen the saw
this is a term we use internally at AWS
to describe the time we spend improving
our technical skills and keeping up to
date with the latest technology Trends
the cloud industry is constantly
evolving and in order to provide the
best architectural guidance to our
customers you're expected to learn new
things every week this could involve
getting AWS certifications catching up
with the latest product updates or
diving deeper into a technical area
you're interested in for example
containers or machine learning in order
to succeed in this field in the long run
you'll need to have the willingness to
proactively develop your technical
skills so if this doesn't sound appear
to you maybe it's best to consider a
different career path
quick pause this video is brought to you
by skillshare skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for anyone who loves
learning and wants to explore their
creativity and learn new skills from
Tech and finance to productivity graphic
design and more you can find classes
that will match with your goals and
interests here is a Class by hashtag
learning providing an absolute
beginner's introduction to Amazon web
services if you're at the start of your
Cloud Learning Journey I would recommend
checking out the class I joined
skillshare to learn more about tech and
productivity and by taking classes like
these I hope to continue building my
skills the first 1000 people to use the
link in the video description below will
get a free one month trial of skillshare
so thank you skillshare for sponsoring
today's video reason number three you
should not become an AWS Solutions
Architects if you want to make a direct
impact now as I've mentioned earlier
Solutions Architects are pretty much
technical advisors for the customer we
provide advice and suggestions on what
customers should build on the cloud and
how they should build it but it's up to
them to do the actual implementation
unlike about architects who can actually
build things out for the customer
Solutions Architects are a lot more
hands-off and at AWS we're actually not
allowed to go into the customer's
account and build anything out for them
it's up to the customer to either do it
themselves or hire someone else for
example a cloud architect so if you
prefer being more Hands-On when working
with customers I would recommend looking
into the cloud Arctic role reason number
four you should not become an AWS
Solutions architect if you want your
role to be very clearly defined this is
a role where you need to learn how to
navigate ambiguity we're not given a
piece of paper that tells us exactly
what we should be doing every single day
so it's our responsibility to figure out
how to juggle our customer work our
internal projects and other commitments
we do have broader essay goals to aim
for as a team but it's up to us to
figure out how to achieve them which is
exciting but at the same time a little
bit intimidating so as a Solutions
architect you'll need to be comfortable
with being uncomfortable I definitely
think this is something you can get used
to over time but if you want a job with
a clearly defined set of
responsibilities then it might be good
to look for a role with less ambiguity
and reason number five is you should not
become an AWS Solutions architect if you
find something else a lot more
fulfilling alright so I recently read a
book that introduces the concept of
ikigai and this is a Japanese term that
Loosely translates to reason for being
according to this book you can use this
as a guide to find your true purpose in
life this can also be applied to your
career essentially an ideal career is
where you get to do what you love do
what you're good at do what the world
needs and do what you can be paid for
I'd recommend spending some time at the
end of this video to try and discover
your own ikigai it might not put you to
an exact job but it will definitely help
you get more clarity on what you value
in the career alright thank you so much
for sticking until the end of this video
please remember to give this video a
like if you got something out of it and
comment below whether you'd still like
to become a Solutions architect alright
bye for now